this is going to be three hours of Blitz
chess against title players
starting now
and playing a grand master for a scheme
um I mean God has at least try a staffer
to start right
because why not
I've lost to this opponent what is F3
is my opponent trolling me or was that a
mouse slip
feels like it could have been a mouse
club Let's Play Bishop C5 first
I mean F3 is just a really bad move
usually in the king's Pond opening
um going for D5
I guess F3 does
uh discourage me from playing a Stafford
though so maybe my opponent was slightly
afraid
not sure the A5 game Space
now Queen B6 threatening the Knight
looks very pleasant
but it still requires
I think some precision and focus
my H3 is not played
and now Pawn's a little bit tender
Bishop there takes
I could play this move too
I think I'll just play this just
complete development I mean if takes
takes takes
I lose upon the get initiative
should be okay
I might be threatening D4
takes takes
all right let's play this move idea
Knight B4
it's the benefit of the pawn not being
able to move backwards
before is accessible
uh Bishop E3 is an idea
so let's do this anyway
Bishop B1 man
can I take
c3's coming
maybe I could play like D4 do you want
to close things down though
and start with this
the C3 I moved back
Bishop E3 maybe D4 and then
trying to keep the pace
okay D4 now takes takes
might as well this bishop is kind of
dead
ideas of Knight C5 Knight B3
I mean this Pawn restricts a bishop
also restricts this Pawn which restricts
the other Bishop
uh let's attack The Rook oh this wins
material Rook A2 Knight C1
the first rank Fork
or the back ring Fork
in Rogue A3 I just take it so the rook's
essentially chopped
horsey went on a journey
all right Bishop B4
we need this move first
time for the other horsey to shine
G4 let's play this B5 idea
gradually preparing B5
oh I got to play there right away and
then C pawns pinned
thank you cows Shield happy 10.
okay but a little bit of time up
material
take
so if Bishop takes I think I'm happy to
trade and then
okay depending what takes back
play this
hitting the queen and Pawn
B3 is probably coming
maybe I sack
maybe this first
and a five Bishop f8
hacking no longer really makes sense
I want to Target B3
always play off six
slightly questionable move
but I free the square B3 is a targets
how to defend hello Eric loads of love
from Germany
keep it up less than three appreciate
that
how do you say love in German
Amore is love in Spanish
and this is not so simple
uh King G7
[Music]
swing The Rook over
I should win on time at the very least
maybe checkmate at the very most
okay making progress
uh
Chuck
okay pretty clean game
I'm not sure if my opponent was playing
a troll opening or just a mouse slip
opening with F3
like has this ever been played in a in
Master Level play
once
but it's already like not good for white
okay I'll take it
called the king's head opening
appointment with went head first with
the F Pawn
thank you Cole
appreciate the bits and the words
thank you
positelo pasataleo
and frix DD
all right
um play I'll play my main
opening
London opening time
got a copycats
play C4
have a good score against this opponents
and this is like a London Queen's Gambit
hybrid
resembling some Queens got accepted
all right Bishop before probably coming
[Music]
try and keep some Tempo here
I'll take with Knight
a lot of natural moves D5 wait D5 B5
Bishop recently discovered that there is
nothing in the chess rule book that says
you can't kidnap your opponent's family
and threaten them unless he loses good
luck
um
that's an interesting realization
uh I think I just blundered a thing
um
how to do
B3
I'm just losing a pawn
Bishop D3
or Bishop A2
all right let's play this
uh difficult position oh yes my sub good
to see you Eric
good to see you too even though I'm not
really looking at you right now
have a position to focus on
like Rook D1 maybe go for E4
okay foreign
YouTube X Clan extra
all right so I mean E4 is
an idea
a bishop D3 man
H4
E4 take no
let's start with H4
this is terrifying
some Knights 97 the C6 idea
already down over a minute
there's almost an idea where I take
everything
never mind
have to take
still not upon I mean E4 is still an
idea
never mind
but maybe still
yeah the B file is going to be an issue
I think this
F3 restricting the knights
so C3 take take Bishop C2
try this
uh oh
that's not good
yeah I'm gonna need a miracle here
not meant to be
oops
okay
oh what to do good game
um what did I miss that game like this
Knight B6 move losing a pawn early on
okay let me open up this request queue
so on yesterday's stream I enabled
opening requests
through Channel points
and I got some requests yesterday as
well so this is a request list
um
I don't think there were any black
openings against E4 Let's uh berserk and
play let's go for a Stafford
wait let's cut off oh sorry about that
ratings are cut off
thanks for letting me know
I don't know how that happened
hopefully that's better
okay I deserved here uh
what's the line 94
we're going into one of the sharper
standard lines
F5 or no Bishop here first and then
at five comes next
objectively this is a little bit better
for whites but it does get a bit weird
okay just still Castle
idea being after it takes I take back
and defend the bishop
and there's some counter play
actually looks like there's a lot of
counter play here E3 is a big threat if
Queen takes I develop a tempo
I mean there is this Chuck King HH
but we're looking on D1 and open
position
I think it's it's at the very least more
enjoyable for black
but how to make progress
Queen G5
preparing this attacking this
maybe you're preparing this and this
Queen F4 I can play Queen G6
yeah and this is a big threat I guess
there's Queen A4
after Queen A4 maybe I just start Pawn
swarming hello sir you are looking very
handsome today oh thank you
Lord borrow
wow Maiden two
check
and mates okay that was uh that was
actually a fun game stopper gambits
appointment went for
uh
slightly um lesser common line D3 C3
and then we saw all the fun that the
Stafford can can bring
despite losing a piece
okay back to tournaments
got some berserking points
what's happening
not sure if my internet's lagging or the
site's lagging
top 60.
move on
hope you're having a good day in Rose
and ducky oh thank you biblio penguin
yeah thanks to everyone who maybe I
didn't acknowledge as well
Samsonite earlier gifting a sub
grandmas just a roon
oh who's trying to let me know yeah
hopefully the layout is better now
[Music]
um
something got a little bit off
ah maybe this is what happened
yeah while my opponent takes her time
there we go just trying to maximize the
board size
okay
sometimes I'm overly perfectionist when
it comes to easily outs
uh E4 is a move
at Bishop D7
takes latsuku
welcome back to eulers
hi Eric hello
but remember correctly there's 92 I
don't think E5 is a move
it's a pair of 92 it takes I think it's
I think it's takes first
remember I played a similar lining in
sakaru
crush me
and I briefly checked the improvements
this is the only move I remember and
like Queen D2
maybe just casting King's side
Queen A4 is a move
Queen D3
let's play Queen D3
preventing vegetable five Queen has some
potential to swing over
if Knight B4 or I mean the lights pinned
so if castling castling night before I
move back
5 Knight D4 attacking and defending
oh shallows for my opponents who's also
streaming
yeah I don't actually recognize his name
maybe streaming in Spanish
from Mexico
all right so I could take
I think this is okay though
let me put the bishop back on B3
and Rook D1
okay so Bishop F5 is now uh
realistic idea
I mean there's an id4
Queen and queen F3
a D4 might be coming
take a queen F3 should be fine
so D4 I take take take
or D4 take take
I think I'm winning a pawn
block has a bishop pair
I have this move I may have missed
Knight takes C6
I still have it though
because I'm threatening the bishop if
takes High Fork
this is also an idea
yeah I think this is completely winning
for white
um
let's win the queen
hitting this and this
there's one check King H2
[Music]
okay pretty smooth game
top 100 two in a row
oh top 60.
welcome back to Pam
obese Reese Magnus is playing wait what
wow Magnus is playing
when was the last time Magnus played on
leechas
not since like the the merger right
so maybe he's not like completely
exclusive to
chess.com
that's cool
long time no see Dr nitrosine
let's play this move
um I'll go for the line takes Knight H5
oh dear I just lost a piece
just lost a piece
all right let's treat it as a a gamut
I'm used to being that material
take this
problem is Queen E3
yeah this move
okay have some work to do
I do have two pawns for the piece
defend the sad story for the bishop but
defending things
take take
I think this is playable so takes takes
takes
takes takes here here and then takes
yeah F4 I take in the end
I'm ready to play this move
and now the knights attacked okay so
take
so F4 I take I mean there's Rook here
then this move
I have no time to contemplate
now we're simplifying
that's going to be equal equal Pawns
I'm trying to win one of these things
draw no
draw
okay can't complain I mean
I was down the piece after like the
first 10 moves
okay so now the goal is to get high
enough so I can play Magnus
uh let's play this move
B4
I think this is playable
it's like a Polish kinda
exotic position
this diagonal's a little bit weak
Bishop B7
uh Bishop's actually decently placed
there
okay I probably have to take with
knights I could take with Queen though
yeah because it takes I win the E2 Pawn
A4
hitting the bishop heading this
and the issue for white the Knight can't
move to defend the queen
Knight's pin to the queen
it's a weird uh weird tactic dull but
I'm losing a piece back
four comes by Winnie two
Bishop F1 the tactics just keep coming
I think it's okay
but what's happening
take
the four
okay this is where I slow down and
calculate
um
a queen C4 maybe is simple
wait Queen C4 hangs a piece
let me try this it's going to be an
exchange sock and then Queen C4
so I'm kind of thing takes takes takes
takes diagonal opens The Bishop's
attacks
um Bishop A3 in the end
and then this move this was extend to my
calculation do I have another move
oh there's rookie one
I think I can move the knights unless I
play like this
that's not good
I think I'll play this first
and there's still compensation
wait why did I do that
giving way too many Tempe
okay
I really mishandled this
still maybe playable maybe not though
I'll also thread
I had a good position
[Music]
what to do
I have five seconds left
okay uh
not my proudest game
still top hundred
lost my streak lost my 2600 rating
I'm tied with Bortnick
unexpectedly who seems to be berserking
all his games
Magnus wow Magnus berserk winning
29 tournament points
hey it's Anna kramling
what's up underground shout out to Anna
hope you had a good stream if you're
just joining
I started streaming about half hour ago
and I'll be streaming for the next at
least two and a half hours
playing some chess
it's
um it's July 1st
it's a July titled Blitz Arena
what I played five games so far
lost to one three I think
okay
oh and the crownling is actually
um makes a an appearance in my most
recent YouTube video
and the crowdling is a reason why my
most recent YouTube video
uh exists
because she was the one who helped
provide the camera also did I just
blunder
oh dear
okay that's not so bad though
Bishop
it's also Knight D5
trade off the knights this bishop is so
strong
you see three
maybe he could have taken here
okay this bishop is strong this Bishop's
a little bit sad
what to do
in good night S6 I just take it
Bishop 6 makes sense
so maybe this move
undouble the Pawns
ah that was a good move
take take
let's try
I lose a pawn there
let's try it though
so there's take Stakes Rook F2 King G1
Rook B2 Bishop E6 in the end
D6 is attacked
okay here let's contest a file
so if it takes maybe okay never mind
I really have to watch my time
Rook F4
I mean we're both trying to attack on
the king side
and these both minor pieces are actually
quite strong
I was beginning to feel like white has a
bit more coordination
I really don't care about the queen sign
even though maybe I should
H5 idea
I'm not sure what that was
the B file is open now though
if we trade like G4 is a threat
I take take
start with this
Queen G4 Also let's play this
so I'm threatening this
wow
foreign
just blocking the attack
Frick moves I have check and queen F6
I think E4 is an important move
limit all the counter play
this is made in two that's a funny
Maiden two
Rook G8
so if Queen takes Queen F6 mate if King
takes Queen f8 Maids
that's pretty aesthetic
okay back over 2600
not the easiest of games
a nice one to win
trying to catch up to Magnus
who is in second place
has won all his games
thank you Ryan Vincent
happy one year
okay uh I'm using the smart berserk
extension if it tells me it's a dessert
I berserk
there we go
okay so this is more of a bullet game
I'm gonna try and expand on the king
side
maybe maneuver the Knight
oh
it's already like close to
being Tactical
I want to go for that
maybe I do
let's go Eric let's go let's go
I'm doing something that maybe I
shouldn't do
it looked too interesting though
so I'm winning the pawn maybe I'm not
winning the pawn
two first
yeah the light's a little bit awkward
here
I'm trying to justify it there's some F4
idea
let's move first
F4
yeah Bishop C5 at some point
here it's Chapman in one
oh and if here I have rookie two
checkmates okay
that was a funny finish I'll take it
thank you Tyler Durden
okay top 50 14 points
all right let's play a soccer Gambit
I had one Stafford earlier and it went
really well
but here we have
maybe a more symmetrical Italian
[Music]
I already like the position
Bishop F5 and E4 oh E4 can't be played
though
hmm
yeah maybe it's not so simple
take
that's actually not so simple here
uh take Knight G6
the Queen's gonna plant itself on e4
maybe the ripple plant itself
so the Knight wants to get to a square
where it attacks E4 but it's very far
away from that
yeah the knights coming in
three let's start with this
if I want to maneuver the knights to one
of these squares
maybe Rook out five to H5
can probably keep ignoring although
let's take once
and then swing over
that's a little bit annoying
play this
you have to be defensive
what to do
C6 is probably coming
C6 I have D5
now you see five I'd probably take and
take
I broke off seven I'm wondering if I can
take first
probably
yeah there's a lot of lines where I saw
the exchange and
have a monster night
wow
so White's doing the sacking
you know this move first
so Rook B8 here
I prevent Rook C1 this and this are
still attacked along with the c pong
along with apong
that move I forgot about
so I guess I am sagging
so rookie three is tricky but I have
Rook C1
or even Queen B6
foreign
storm along with the king's form
along with the monster Knight yeah
helped out
so that's three in a row two three four
these games are getting the heart
beating
berserk
oh this opponent I drew earlier
I plunder the piece also came from a
London opening
okay
um Queen H3 also E4 makes some sense
oh E4 just blenders upon oops
okay treating it as a Gambit
uh
E4 makes sense when the knights on E2
o shorts
okay so takes takes takes takes
it feels like there's comp here
the PIN
down a bit of time
nature of berserking
okay so I won back the pawn
uh maybe win more Pawns
or B6 Knight C3
Pawn C3 coming
oh good move
oh no
okay I blunder The Rook with rookie Wong
um it's very fortunate
foreign
it's not good I might lose this
I'm losing this
wow
uh
so the reason why I didn't take is
because black has
oh black doesn't have the still Matrix
if I take with Rook
even then there's no sell me trick I was
paranoid of stalematrix
uh what to do
just slowed down there and then
played some bad moves
okay
um
missed a chance to have a really nice
streak
but it's a long tournament
still in the first hour
keep Serene yeah that's what I'll try to
do
lost to this opponent once before
qg The Exchange
yeah with the double G pawns and I
actually is nicely placed on G4
uh okay let's take
Queen can maybe come in
yeah now there's some each file
potential
you know I have like a five to six move
plan to checkmate
one two three four yeah five moves away
it's pleasant but it's not winning
hmm
oh how to crack the position
I think I'll go for the trade
just open the e-file
it does simplify a bit
okay now I'm trying to use the H file
hmm
foreign
there
[Music]
so I think we need four maybe
foreign
worst side of this ending
I have to take
Rook H5 okay here
that's a fine move
okay that's a free rook
okay unexpected gifts
I was getting outplayed there
the pawn Diamond did survive but the
yeah
light's position did not
all right so trying to make another run
a Barman variation
still prep
night is supposed to return I believe
hitting a couple Pawns
and queen E2 is a move
and maybe King f8
Queen D2
so if I take there's taking off seven
I mean let's have some fun
this could really backfire though
happy treysonus
all right so what's happening here
I'm Italian Queen Rooks hanging there's
no discovery check to win the queen
that's why I couldn't take the knights
the queen check I win the knights
there's night Shack and if I take I lose
my queen
Knight check probably King has to move
to dark Square
at this move
oh there's Knight C8
I think the king is relatively safe here
I'm preventing Bach from casting both
ways
and I want to play rookie Eights
very aesthetic arrows
rookie is hard to stop too
okay
rookie three
uh King C2
so without this move
threading this and this
all the fork potential okay
that was a fun game
position got wild like very quickly from
the opening
I played a somewhat risky line but it
paid off
oh yeah I think you Leander valvik for
36 months
all right let's play the unusual stuff
Carlson and third
wow Contra Jocko crushing it
I usually don't play Queen B3 in these
lines but
seems like a move
very similar to the the nepo ding game
that featured the London
foreign
Knight C5
and then probably eventually Trail on C4
if I can
a very positional game
okay so I have the defended pass Pawn
a nice asset
if I take and play Queen C6
between C6 right away looks nice
Pawn's a bit weak
E3 is attacked
I mean there's take
take take
can't quite take on B5 because Queen E1
I play C6 here
Queen B7
not sure if that works
just this first
that's very very close to completely
winning
[Music]
Our Cafe here here here here there
now C7
Queen E1 King H2
okay
that may have been the mouselet but um I
was winning that was a nice game
very positional London got the the
better structure
managed to convert
like you not Scott
uh okay I was debating whether it's a
berserk but
can't physically berserk once the game
begins
hmm
idea Knight B6
and tricky line
knife for it's a weird maneuver
I'm keeping the pawn defended
I'm not repeating I'm just that block is
burning time
uh
have quindy five
and try it
oh
that was a blender
I guess take on F7
maybe some compensation
up a lot of time
a good move
oh I'm in trouble
D7 take take I think D7 might be my best
chance
really botched this
oh no okay I saw this
happy 11 months also trying to be happy
oh not happy
[Music]
let that one slip that was a great
position from the opening under the
piece almost made it works the streams I
missed you too welcome back Matt man
okay playing Harsha
top 50
Carlson and fourth
I'm playing a Stafford repertoire
maybe we'll transpose
yeah this is a good lining in Stafford
still try and get something here
not sure what I have for the pawn
small Edge on time
[Music]
so E5 runs into Knight D5
maybe go for
this idea
I mean this is basically the worst case
scenario
why are you playing against the Staffing
it just plays uh one of the best lines
but I have to work with what I have
thank you
so it takes a skewer
three doesn't work
B6
and queen G5
some A5 eventually
it does feel like there's some
compensation now e-pawn's a Target
Knight G3 rookie five Rook E8 B6
positional compensation
so if I take
rookie five first
what's happening
so there's a line okay take the queen
I can't really make it work though
Bishop here
keeping all the tension
ah good move
I'm burning too much time
some down two Pawns
I want to play this
how to prevent Rook F5
coming back on the clock
foreign
is
I'm down two ponds but look at this
compensation
also look at the time
okay oh what a game
that's how to win with the Stafford
gambits
when the opponent knew the refutation
too
okay
so trying to rebuild a streak
28 points top 50.
I feel like my average Harvey of the
stream has been over a hundred
and try and calm down a little bit here
we had similar line earlier
oh yeah the crazy game earlier
wait a minute
I have to play Knight D5
I think A3 is acceptable
because here I move away
maybe now 95
D5 idea
never mind
E5
nah let's play H4
I think my opponent just forgot about
the PIN
still takes work
just complete development I could take
on D6 but
just seems a bit too risky
[Music]
um
forgot that g3's hanging
and still trying to be really solid
so if I take
whatever it takes there's maybe five
and G6 is also hanging
take her first
and I see two
the tagging attacking
also pinning
maybe winning thank you Matt man gifting
too
I appreciate that
yeah this seems to be completely winning
up two Pawns
winning more material
uh there's a fork
okay
all right trying to move up
two in a row
ing around 50th
so I've had two three-game win streaks
playing Rob
's a very strong player Eric I asked
dispatch to have some ambulances on
standby oh good to know very good to
know
Bishop G5
[Music]
might just do some Trading
I think you stupid Meister
take that
should play A6 probably
G6
not the most comfortable position
a knight F5 is coming
another five Queen E5
oh that's not good
indie forchak
very strong Player for my opponents
try this
so now I am threatening to take
okay somehow I think that worked out
holding on to extra peace
someone getting merch
garage purchase do you even rock cliff
bro muscle and tank top for thirty
dollars thank you Garrett
okay F5
oh no my Pawn
a queen of six
being extra careful here
yeah this simplifies nicely
almost plundered in night
okay
just not got too long time
top 40.
I'm not berserking back I'd need chances
so I'll accept the time odds
A6 let's play this anyway
Bishop
I'm just about four
and there's this this
interesting position
wow
they take the latex
closings down
the thing is my Bishop is completely
stuck
what to do
um
so I want to maneuver the Knight to F4
plan is this this is
Queen C1 so tricky
and King D2
King E2
F4 opens the bishop
maybe lift The Rook
I don't see how to make progress
maybe G4 eventually
I have this move
tactics
more tactics okay
a crazy position man Bishop proves to be
useful without moving
let's go
top 30.
four in a row it's the longest
streakless tournament
wow tied with portnick Bortnick is
usually like is leading these events
Magnus having a rocky tournament playing
this opponent again
on a good win streak against this
opponents
is this a Stafford game
no that wasn't the soccer game
we might have this oh we have this line
okay
it was like one of the most basic traps
Bishop D4 H5
attack
be Queen G5
which would be five idea
I mean G3 is a Target now
I prevent Knight E3
four might be coming
I have H4
so if D4 Bishop G3 check
probably Bishop G3 anyway
this move
attacking both Pawns
and now I take
kind of takes uh Bishop C4
okay 19 moves to offered win
I'll take it
24th
five in a row
so only three losses right or four
losses
okay we have Vienna 22.
not sure if this is a line
idea Knight D4
I may have just plundered like takes
oh man
take first
I don't think this works though
does it takes takes takes here
kingy two
we don't go into that
crazy position already
take again
I think I have to take
hmm
I really want to play this move
so I might as well
hmm
I'd see six
I'm down the pond this crazy position
[Music]
four is probably coming
to take
hmm
um a five take take
try this first
I burned away all my time advantage
still not a pawn
we're coming
I might windy five as well
foreign
got the job done there
six in a row
still top 30.
I think this is on Drake and
vladimirovich oh I'm playing uh vasif
Dura Bailey
former teammate of mine
sorry receive I'm on a big win streak
I'm not berserking back
let's see his London prep this line
Queen B6
I think I can take
care
[Music]
I think the night night's tied down to
defending the F Pawn
we can take
I mean D2 hangs
do it
oh
I missed a few things there
might be three
foreign
by the way he's also streaming
uh Queen F3 you're just castling
uh
difficult position already
hitting both Pawns
yeah Bishop G4 was annoying
hmm
and G4
G4 H5 though
wow
that's not meat
uh
well played
crazy game
okay there goes my streak
Gigi
and I think it's like thunderstorming
oh this is on Dragon right
yeah this is on Dragon
Stafford gamut against on draken
King's got it
let's play the uh the fog through
counter gamuts
he's not even berserking me
oh okay
I'm draken's like
very strong chess player
but we're going into like one of these
lines Bishop D2 E3
there's takes takes Queen E2
maybe a main line
I like that he's taking time here
maybe manually berserking oh he's also
streaming too
all these Grand Master streamers
okay let's take
Queen near
Rook beam one
yeah the reason for going for this even
though Bishop B2 comes with Tempo I play
Queen D6
man there's some lightning outside
[Music]
I don't think Chad can hear it but it's
kind of loud
the Thunder is loud
oh to do C5
your Rook e8's most flexible
some E3 idea never mind
play in this move
almost didn't see that was hanging
I take
because it takes oh no my lights are
flickering if this dream dies
of it's because the power probably has
gone out
there are really bad storms last night
in St Louis
it was actually hailing last night's
large ice balls falling from the sky
no not C5
in this move
um
busy be sudden
E3 is actually coming very soon
but do I want it
probably
happy Bishop
A4 oh Knight D4 is coming maybe this
move
no
I don't know what to do I have to move
quickly
that was a bad decision
there there
is and games not good
at least hold on to the a pawn
oh he can take the a pawn though
maybe some counter play like
takes in here
Rook B2
The Rook is hungry
man
I kind of want to turn off the noise
suppression filter it's so loud outside
take
still looks playable
oh
check there
okay
every E3 didn't work
thank you
uh what to do
good game
that's a good fight
first time losing two in a row
had chances until losing the piece in
that game
okay it doesn't get easier though
other Grand Master who is this
anonymous
I'm on the wrong type of streak
I think Bishop H6 was actually called
for
play this first
I may have already like plunder and like
takes takes E5 I think I have Queen B4
oh I allowed that
well E5 here
doesn't really do much
G5 doesn't do much
okay I have to play B3
tilt is kind of showing
there's still potential for a fight
although uh
it's not pretty
so I want to take and open the center as
quickly as possible
E5
so what if E5
I promise Knight C3
maybe yeah
and if I take
maybe taking gives me the best chances
what about
[Music]
um
I don't know what to do
foreign
take take
green D4 check there there
let's try this so the calculation is
here takes takes Queen D4 Rook B8 here
would be two Bishop C4
defending A2
burned a lot of time there
I'm actually thankful that like there's
no check I'm controlling all these
squares
this is
so there's no force me immediately
thank you Bitcoin boy
crazy position
wow
I don't have much time
can I take
foreign
because now I'm threatening to take here
Rook B8 and Bishop C4 I think saves me
in this Rook B2 line
wow Magnus in the lead
let me stay focused
[Music]
time is low position's so crazy
what
foreign
just gotta consolidate
that's an amazing position
pure
yeah
oh that's not over
Tricky Tricky
still a good decision
oops
oh
[Music]
oh so angry
what to do
ah I fought so hard to like just be
winning there
got too long time
okay
I just want to play Magnus so it's
really the only goal of this tournament
it's been so long since we played on
mishas
um let's take in Bishop E5 A3 is a move
sometimes
um yeah I'm giving the pawn because of
takes those Queen D4 check
probably lose up on dark stone
a rook beam one
and I want to play G3 before I Castle
it's weakening though
E4
oh I move I completely forgot about
yeah this is
this is pretty bad
okay I'm gonna be down upon ah there's
an id2
uh
yeah the losing streak might continue
[Music]
nice move
I assume that works but
is there a chance it doesn't work Knight
C1
take take their
let's see if my opponent
saw this through all the way
oh they did
uh I probably should have tried
something else but
ended the pain quickly
all right so that's four losses in a row
trying um
yeah let's try and not lose five in a
row
English opening
opponent perplexed
so if London knows uh the line here
it's still a playable position
F4 is a type of move you only play if
you've seen before
um so before
this is one of the plans before and then
take and
um Bishop Basics ideas
maybe I can play 94.
so if takes takes takes I have Knight G5
hitting McQueen
and Rook
C6 is hanging a couple pawns hanging
Queen D6
Knight B6 Rook B8
ambition D7
maybe I couldn't be tricky so takes
takes takes there's
um this move
lights also being tricky
a smooth
oops
forgot I was hanging
because earlier there were tactics but
yeah the poison went away
all right so what to do queen H4
counter play
I want to keep the bishop
hmm
okay there's an idea of takes I take on
E3
some counter play
E4 wow
so
I don't know what to do
nothing looks good the night Soul
monster is
foreign
I just want to play Bishop B5 and not
have to
do with A4
Queen A4 there's bishopath one
D5 might be coming
it's going to take a lot of work to not
lose us
foreign
's played this really well though
yeah E6
what to do
okay
oh what to do
felt like I almost had chances there but
difficult position
so top 50
.
I had an epic winning streak
sometime long long ago
is the nature of a long tournament
though
when someone lusum
coming back to reality
okay this player I played earlier
and Beats
we'll have one of these again
okay so you see five
taking Queen D2
from other Pawn but
not super simple
hmm
and that's actually a very strong move
A3
[Music]
A3 take take take and then C3
oh
okay how bad is this from D6
King D2
so Rook A2 Rook B1 I think I'm barely
holding on
threatening Knight C1 now
the pain is hopefully only temporary
but
yeah maybe longer lasting
or D7 I mean Bishop D3 is actually a big
threat
F3
[Music]
or Knight C1
and I see one
then she'd be three
oh
foreign
[Music]
I don't even know what to do here
yeah
that was rough
I'm trying to um
to not lose the rest of my games
all right I'm still upgrading this
tournament
and this is probably what I need
yeah at this point let's not make any
predictions
I'm already very down
um
C5 let's take
I played this opponent oh that previous
game okay let's improve
do this
yeah I gotta crushed that previous game
and I'm already like not doing well here
you five Bishop G3 Maybe
okay
take
I just want a castle
King Safety First
it's a great move
uh let's play this
every move that feels like I'm getting
punched in the face
but maybe I'm still alive
hey it's Mary chess appreciate the rain
could use some energy now
I'm on a six game losing streak this is
a
July titled Arena
but this game I definitely have some
hope
and I have six is a threats maybe even
check like this
there there it doesn't work
and this move first
okay
[Music]
I think I'm gonna win this
although it's still very okay no it's
not super tricky okay let's go
so Magnus is in first wow berserk
winning so many in a row
Daniel is trying to fight his way
all right let's try and get back on a
streak
a winning streak
[Music]
be more clear
staff org out of time
we haven't had this line yet today
Bishop E2
so H3 and C3 Bishop B3 also playable
um
play Queen D6
I'm just making sure
I haven't had this line in a long time
so there's potential for two Rooks
against the queen
and it's actually a three result game I
think the engine will give like close to
equal here
but why else to be very careful about
the Rooks coordinating and the King
getting mated
which Maybe
is about to happen but maybe not
I take the pawn
I was raining so hard right now
you're here
[Music]
maybe this move
because I want to play this and not lose
this
move
Queen F5 is coming
I think that's okay Queen F5 B6
let's move
[Music]
here here
and the dream is to play this and this
and the King has a pocket of error
hmm
have this
trying to coordinate
if I want to play this and then this
defend
maybe you could have taken
I don't have Rook C5
C5
hmm
foreign
decision
[Music]
maybe a good decision
it's very tricky
so I can defend the pawn but then I have
this move
this is made into or no it's not made
into a1's controlled
this move
I forgot A1 was defended
oh it's still tricky Life Goes On
King finds safety
D7 here here here
should be enough to win I'm not sure
though
I'm feeling the fatigue of having played
so many games
I could take but I think taking is fine
we might see under promotion tonight
yeah like here
and then promote tonight
uh
but this is a big threat
I think my opponent was trying to figure
out how to disable auto Queen
because this is not the move that you
you spend all your time to play
um not that it would have mattered if
Knight if promotes a night I would just
check
and there is still threats
okay that was a cool game
so uh back on a win streak 50 tournament
points Magnus has 131
jb2 mix
who is this name sounds familiar
oh this is uh bonawa
okay good player
but having internet issues
um D5 is the main move I'll play E3
played a similar line earlier
they're having a lot of issues
there is a lot of condensation but up
until a point
foreign
[Music]
E2 probably
defending the bishop
and B6 expected
I would like to play E4 but there's this
forking idea
so maybe D5 first
let me get a benoni structure
F5 is is pretty thematic
F5 maybe still E4
[Music]
oh
and these nights are nice
it could be a Target to
and can I take on D6 and win The Rook
let me just do it
objectively maybe this was a wrong
decision but it's interesting
very imbalanced now
have a lot of Pawns three Pawns
another four play F4 F4 F5
hmm
[Music]
all right let's play this first
for queen of three
I'm gonna eventually play this and this
C4 E5
monster pawns tricky move
very tricky
plundered
Rook was hanging for a moment there
foreign
[Music]
good game that was a good fight
that's a great position just couldn't
convert
okay hovering around number 50.
40 minutes left
I'm still operating I've gained about 30
points
started the tournament around 2600.
playing with Vlad G
uh let's play the slime
so there's a line G6 and then E4
is a fun one
I think E5 here
yeah Knight takes E4 is supposed to be
more critical like Queen E2
I mean this looks really fun
wow
trying to comprehend everything here
so
and I could play Queen E2 we trade
Bishop
G7
maybe five there's also Bishop E2
three
let's keep Queens on the board
there's Knight A5
three doesn't work
it's 25
Queen B6 could
I need just some repeating
foreign
fight
in here
foreign
is kind of hanging
32 miss ya less than three
happy 32
foreign
okay
F4 is slowed uh slowed my opponent down
a little bit it's
it's very conflicting which Pawn to take
on passant with
okay
thank you zippy
happy 32
miss you too
okay top 50
playing Gannicus
Stafford Gambit time
no Saturn gambits thank you blueprints
this is a fun line
um
I could take
him Bishop E7
wow Bishop F5
probably I just do my own thing Castle
[Music]
wow
Grand Master Level play
D4
I can't defend the pawn
maybe Queenie Aiden Rook dates
F6
it's actually a really annoying position
let's play this
at least have some blockade
six sometime soon
only tea left till two years let's go
thank you for the great work you do
oh thank you rocker hotter
that name sounds
Icelandic or Scandinavian
I appreciate the words
in this move
some interesting compensation here
that doesn't work let's play B5
and this and then F6
I should be winning the pawn
and the resulting position
[Music]
is actually quite Pleasant
although
C7 hangs
ac6
take take
this
hmm
tricky
very tricky
there we go okay final position was
winning too
I was close though
really close
okay
trying to get a longer streak
okay that's um
lost to this player before we had that
really crazy
aren't
staff for Gambit time
yeah this is Joel bonawa
his name is on his account I know he's a
I think he's a pretty active chess coach
so he probably teaches the students how
to refute the staff right now
but we'll see how prepped he is
playing the magical line
haven't had this position today
we have had a decent number of staffords
also have a pretty good score with the
staffer today
a lot of players
walking into early tricks
and I wonder if we've gone into this
line before
like we've played over 20 times
hey it's vampire chicken
yeah this is very very magical
shout out to vampire chicken who's a
Godfather of this line
or the god chicken
all right so I can take
here no Rook G1 and then Queen H4
there's a line where I sacked two pieces
I already sacked one piece so
yeah after takes
King D2 okay
you can take here
and this already looks pretty good for
luck
compensation
rookie one I probably just Castle
oh
here I can take the bishop with tempo
guess he wants queen E1 so maybe I'll
take with a rook
then I have to catch you at the line
where I sack then we just trade Bishops
yeah this looks very nice
in this move
idea of take some Bishop G5
hey that's my go 5000.
I appreciate the gifted Subs
yeah this is just a really nice position
so
let me try not to screw it up
G2
maybe F5
C5 Sony options
I like G2 though
check
I really want to take
this move
this actually looks pretty
straightforward
Bishop's pin to the queen
Rooks defended upon's defended
rookie one is off limits
and so is nylophone
and I have one played so I can take
oh yes my queen
[Music]
I'll be up a bishop in the end
um take
he's a fighter though
but yeah it's it's stabilizing
foreign
eventually want to coordinate
on C3
oh oh
wow that's a move
nice move
okay it's still winning I think
Maybe
probably
he was super resourceful there though
okay I could have built the bridge but
what to do
all right that was a nice soccer game
Pat um
I mean just had like a nice opening prep
and
some point whites got in trouble
I still haven't played Magnus
or Rebecca Harris
let's play one of these
yeah G6 is a huge weakness
I probably just abandoned The Rook
go for Queen H5
not meeting
and there's this move check there there
not seeing mates
wait a minute
oh now I see mates
so King here it's me King here it's
check here check
here check here G3 checkmates
and this one's a queen
probably still amazing soon
okay
that's a fun game
are you trying to learn happy 49
[Music]
so trying to finish strong top 20 or no
top um top 40 less than 20 minutes left
okay so we have maybe another staffer
Gambit
who is this
Anonymous Gia
Bishop E3
let's go let's go
so King D2 there's this funny trap
this is the best move
the objectively black is worse here
still threatening to take
this I don't think is so bad
um take on F1 so I won back the pawn
stable position
King seven
I don't know what to do
C5
yeah should I take the knights
trying to be safe
there's this idea
or D5 C6
again it's really up to my opponent to
try and win this I'm just gonna hold my
ground
G6
and King here first
foreign
passer should be winning
I mean G5 is a move
kind of like this move
it's kind of passive though
uh
what about G5 no it doesn't work
C6
so I want to mobilize a rook over
defending the pawn
takes
and this first
um
maybe now G5
oh King's ready to come in
yeah I'm kind of panicking
it's probably losing
um
we'll just keep waiting
hmm
B5 take
there's nothing to do here
yeah well played
okay
uh got ground down there that was rough
maybe it was slightly worse than the
Rook ending and then
a gradually went downhill
thank you chess King Kong
oh yeah my pleasure yeah there has been
a lot of like exclusive YouTube content
like a lot of my recent videos were
videos that were not previously streamed
on Twitch
including the most recent one
playing Alexandra botez in Iceland
on national TV
um let's play it's a little bit weird of
the setup
maybe F5
um
this
I like the position
looks very solid
some attacking potential
for
[Music]
just to open the bishop
H3 I probably just moved back
I'm not sure what the plan is
right here
take
just moving too slowly
wait what oh wow
take take
I'm gonna play 94.
I just plunder that
fatigue is setting in
.
foreign
tricks Maybe
uh well played
um
okay
all right let's try and finish strong no
more losing for the rest of the
tournament maybe hopefully
63 tournament points playing Pavel Mart
I haven't played enough E4 today so
mixing it up thank you Urban pancakes
nine months
and babies
um someday Maybe
play what is this Knight D5
this
okay so I've induced the double Pawns
now it's time to play in the style of a
Grand Prix
probably E5 first and then Castle
So eventually I want to go for F5
somebody see six ideas
seems like a pleasant position
[Music]
some G4 idea
wow
I still probably want to go for this
do I have to worry about G5
G5 King G3 take take
that's interesting
hmm
foreign
yeah I mean then they can come to E4
the hope is that I just play King E2 and
the King should be safe and then F5
eventually
okay here
I guess I can't really take
Magnus just crushing it wow
yeah this will be one of the last games
not the last though
Queen E3
can also consider taking now
my taking is probably really bad
and this move
holding on for dear life
a very clunky setup
if I take there is uh this check
now if I take check
I think it's okay
foreign
[Music]
okay wow oh no my queen good try
I can't wait can I take that no I can't
very good try
okay oh yes my queen trade
foreign
that was the final game
oh that was the final game
uh let me just show the moment in that
game
it was very clever I almost fell for it
too
Bishop T8
I saw the idea like a few moves prior
like once I play King G3 I realized if
the bishop comes to H4 there's some
amazing potential
so
yeah so I offered the queen train
opponent played here
which just looks like a queen blunder
but if I take the queen then check and
the Bishops work really well together I
have to take the pawn and then
Bishop E1 checkmates
such as Savage mate
congratulations to Magnus
wow winning a title Arena it's been a
long time since Magnus played the title
Arena
which is working a lot
thanks to everyone who's subbed and
resubbed Eric is the king
Magnus is a the bigger King
185 points
I finished with 65 points
Magnus like almost tripled my score
I played 36 games total
my performance rating was over 2700.
I gained about what 40 points
43 points
so if this goes on YouTube in the future
hello to YouTube let me know in the
comments to your favorite game
I'll probably time stamp all the games
so check them out and stay tuned for
more content